hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play cold fusion ok
this is a game that you guys have been
recommending for me in the past two days
like unbelievably amount and I saw the
yamimash played it I didn't see his
video so I don't know what's going on
into it but I'm gonna steal another game
of his and there's not a thing you can
do about it ok enough being silly
a research team
okay well that was a lot of story in a
very short amount of time why me and me
alone why do I need to be alone in this
venture this seems like it's really
important if it can power the entire
eastern seaboard for 2,000 years why not
the whole country for 1,000 maybe you
wanted to spread the love around or you
just selfish just stupid eastern
seaboard of America
I'm guessing okay alright let's go into
this place I'm sure it's gonna be lovely
there's gonna be plenty of lighting cuz
I got all that power from this machine
and I'm sure that every scientist in
they're gonna be at Oh
Jerry Jerry just tripped over the wired
plug in the wall do I have a flashlight
Oh
yeah that's a good sign it is gonna be
great can't wait it's gonna be fun fun
fun on a bun you know for a place with
unlimited power they seem to have some
trouble with the lighting was that a
body being dragged Oh Jana Rama haven't
seen that before
let's see her shopman the darkness can't
quite see it okay so there's random
bodies being dragged along the dirt Oh
is someone turning on more light over
there hello is someone alive
seriously this is supposed to be us I
swear I see something down there
something some fur fur a super-advanced
amazing facility this looks like it was
made back in the 60s when they still had
child labor laws or not in the 60s back
in the 20s when they still had child
labor laws and everything was just a
giant sweatshop is that a blood stain
hmm Oh suspicious
okay key card required is this a key
card haha ah come on I thought I got a
key card picked up something okay I
probably got a key card for another area
of the facility can I run I can't even
run excuse me be careful with that
equipment you're handling okay so I'm
guessing that there are doors on the
other side of the set I'm barely making
out the windows to the doors that's why
I think I'm seeing over there but it's
really dark in this game I'm gonna try
to bump it up a bit in post for you guys
but I am in the fog hello these are
either monster eyes or a door I'm not
sure which okay it's a door good F okay
so this key goes to this
how's moderately surprising I suppose Oh
No
dead body so scary okay you're gonna
have to do better than that game get me
get me I got my volume like cranked up
to the maximum
I have highly refund okay alright then
is that it
come on bring it on game
bring it on as I was saying before I've
highly refined horror game senses I'm
not so easily tricked by your Trixie
Trixie Ness so anyway we're continuing
down there's also another bug I noticed
I play in windowed mode just to make it
easier to record and the mouse is still
on the outside of the game and needs to
be fixed hella huh is someone down this
hallway does someone want to tangle with
the likes of me
no oh I can run it's just very slow no
can't I yeah very slight very very slick
what how many damn key cards do I need
in this place and what reckless
scientists would just leave their key
cards lying all over the floor no I
would expect sterile environments white
walls cleaning rooms you know air
chambers to keep air filtration out of
certain sections of the place lovely
stuff like that but new we've got dead
bodies flying out of the ventilation
system everything's just going to crap
so come on let me just take care of the
monster with my gun do I even have a gun
I don't even have a gun do I can I even
go in here hello what is that can tell
what that is oh whoa whoa where'd that
come from
okey-dokey then hello sir keycard in
here that I could use blood on the table
papers on the ground it says nothing
here for me to use could I just get on
the table and lace essentially waiting
for the monster to get me Oh paint me
like what if you're dead scientists yeah
okay anyway enough creepiness aside I'm
being more creepy than this game is okay
hi table is it's decided scoot a little
bit closer let me look at this equation
here yeah yes hmm I know some of these
symbols hmm this is science that's
science right there okay anyway nothing
here no key cards that I've seen the
doorway seemed to be just a little too
low clearance for me can I open this
door please yes maybe yes okay I can
open this door hello
there's someone ah there's someone
trying to get me
hello table you decide - I'm just so
attracted to tables or tables are
attracted to me they just want to move
closer is there something in the
darkness here I'm just gonna back into
it
nope edge of the wall there's nothing
here what was the point of coming down
here is there like a ah there we go key
card got a key card
now what door this key car goes to is a
mystery a mystery that I will soon solve
or not or I'll die horribly I can only
hope one can only hope
I'm going jump out at me I like that
music it's the first time the music's
been interesting the sort of rumbling
deep bass it chills your soul or
something like that
hello was there anything any or now I'm
thinking that there might have been like
a key card on the floor or something
that I might have missed man this guy is
this guy a soldier or what he can't
sprint he can't move you can't do
anything he's like he doesn't even come
in with a flashlight not even a gun not
even like a knife or anything to defend
himself with what was he afraid that he
was gonna blob I like how that I have a
string quartet behind me every time
something pops out just four guys by me
just that was happening really really
pretty little blue and then you know go
around there
naturelle was in dead space yeah the
whole Orchestra and dead space behind
you every time like I'm a monster Billie
Lou and then everyone start playing
behind you
it'd be fun ah come on it's got to be
for the other door I thought it would be
the for the close one it's for the
really far away one whatever whatever
I'll just wander very very slowly down
these dark holes are you having fun
everybody who needs to use a key I
already open that damn door oh is that
the same dead body is he doing the
splits now sick moves bro I see you've
been doing your exercises hi was that
was that a vent falling from the ceiling
reminds me of the inception button hasty
press that like okay cool
can't see what I'm walking into can't
even see where I'm walking into it but
all right what do we got I cannot see a
damn thing
did I pick something up I heard a noise
I think I might have picked something up
did I I'm not sure was it a keycard and
if so what was the point of getting a
keycard to go to a door just to pick up
another key card isn't that little waste
of time going back and forth for no
arbitrary reason not even an arbitrary
reason just no reason at all
I either way let's just keep moving
forward
don't question game logic let's just
keep moving forward I think this is a
plot device to get me to move through
the hall so that they can throw more
things at me
ah Oh somebody oh there's nothing behind
me there's a string quartet behind me
they're chasing me oh sorry my bad
alright hopefully I can open this hall
now because I think I picked up
something it was that same noise that I
heard before when I was picking up the
other thing so I can only assume hi
another dead body you know I see all
these dead bodies where's the monster
just talking to the ceiling cuz that's
where all the dead bodies are coming
from is that with her like the dead
bodies right I'm gonna die right here
and then I time it so that my arms and
now got him yeah nail scared him so bad
good for me I did I couldn't do anything
in life but I did one thing in death
okay anything on the ground here
something maybe anyone something
hahaha no no coming ah don't kill me
baby boo oh that wasn't gonna kill me oh
that's gonna kill me
I don't think thing there we got a
musher it looks like one of those creepy
crawlies from have I do a line Queen's
I'm so glad that I'm moving so fast
running away from this thing this is
fantastic
hahahahahaha I started running as soon
as I saw the thing but as you can see my
soldier guy was just I can look reason
you and out huh and the spring quartet
was like hanging on my back is it really
no you better run faster bro
I'm trying you're on my back and then
build a little little okay so I'm not
gonna try it again cuz it took me
forever to get through it anyway and get
the key carts to go through it ah yeah
you know it's not that I wasn't trying
to be scared that's all I was trying to
do is you know I got dark room
headphones very loud it just it didn't
click with me you know it didn't click
with me I don't know why because I've
been in similar situations before I was
just in it with stairs it was very
similar thing to it but at the same time
there were just a few things that
detracted me from the experience I mean
like the first jump scare wasn't very
profound at all if you could call it
that it was the body being dragged away
and as soon as you see like a body in
the corners being dragged it's not
particularly scary at all and I don't
know why it just was worked by the fact
that I had to run back and forth it with
no reason going back and forth to find
these key cards and I was a supposed
soldier you you made the concerted
effort to tell the story that I was an
agent or a special agent or a super
special forces guy going into this when
I'm thinking that I'm thinking I at
least have some equipment and training
and can run relatively quickly there is
some reality that needs to be based on
these horror games and along those lines
you established this storyline that was
totally inconsistent as soon as I got in
the game like as soon as I got in the
game I noticed I was slow I didn't have
anything not even a flashlight you
wouldn't even think that anyone going
into this building being sent into a
building would have a flashlight no
backup the premise is just totally in
kits like it doesn't make any sense at
all so that was a that was a sort of
disconnect because a horror game even if
it's based in Supernatural things needs
to make sense in some way and also the
atmosphere was just too dark I couldn't
even see if anything was in the darkness
at all like
itself isn't scary it's the idea that
there's something in there and that
wasn't even like a clue like noises
behind me there was just the same I'm
been a little a little with the strings
and then there was like um this the the
music once it started going that bass
was kind of cool but they didn't do
anything with it it was just the same
thing over and over again it was it
reminded me of the slender thing where
just a big bass drum but at least with
that as you got more pages it added on
top of it and laid more tension into it
overall I don't know I I hate making
judgments about these games it's just
I'm telling you my opinion of it and how
I how I felt when I was playing it I
wasn't particularly scared at all during
that game but that doesn't mean that you
couldn't beat I'll try it for yourselves
I'll leave the judgment up to you I
don't like judging it because I really
appreciate when people go through the
effort to make these games I'm not
criticizing them for their attempt at
making it let's look at the credits
because I want to give people credit
where is due and oh look at this see
they got it they got a cool thing okay
and I never saw while I tones ColdFusion
and it was just like it was a cool
concept in it in and of itself and the
idea behind the story was sure yeah it'd
make a great story and I bet it was in
the twilight zone but I I don't know I
can't I cook I couldn't get into it that
was the only problem that's it's really
loud you can check that out for yourself
but I'm not sure if that music is
copyrighted either so try for yourself
link is in the description I will leave
the judgment up to you you can play it
have fun with it
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye
like that we're funny man funny man